Chris is in Utah hi Chris welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hey babe it's an artist
yeah - how you doing better than I
deserve sir what's up so here's what I'm
at Dave I'm a recent listener and I
can't say I have an iron am I'm charged
up by a truck driver so I listen to
audible I downloaded financial piece
visited Total Money Makeover my smell I
think using every dollar budget out this
month and it's phenomenal and I'm just
pumped up so I'm just trying to get her
as onboard as I am maybe I'm just
thinking I'd ask you suggestions with
their path listeners we thought about it
but I don't know how available it is out
here Heat's off on Saturdays and
spending a day time home so maybe get
some suggestions to kind of get her
pumped up with me okay well the mistake
most guys make when they get amped up
about this is they start talking about
what we're gonna do and she doesn't care
what we're gonna do until she knows why
we're gonna do it so don't talk about
the why talk about the why if we didn't
have any payments what could we do we
could build wealth if we didn't have any
payments what could we do we could fund
the kids college fund if we didn't have
any payments we could travel if we
didn't have any payments we could be
more generous if we didn't have any
payments what is the thing that lights
her up that you could do if you weren't
broke and that's the thing
and so that's why that's your why you
need to dream with her and come up with
your why and go okay now then what's the
best way to not be broke get rid of the
debt now we have a reason if they're you
know if it lights her up and she says
you know I really am scared that we're
not gonna send our kids to college and
you go that's right I think you're right
I don't think we're gonna be able send
our kids to college unless we get out of
debt but you know if we didn't have any
payments we can see in the kids college
couldn't wait yeah well then let's let's
get rid of these debts
let's work together because now you got
the why in front of what because a lot
of guys just get excited and call her
and go hey honey I'm selling your car
which of course goes over like not at
all right
you know yeah and so we're desperately
bad most guys me included about talking
about the what rather than the why if
you get the why right everybody also
follow along that's true when you're
leading inside your organization if
you're a leader and you're listening to
me out there running a business or
running a non-profit or whatever it's
true when you're in a household you got
to get the Hawaii before you do the what
and when you get that on the right order
you'll be fine and that's what's
happened to you by the way you started
to believe that this was possible and
that's what and that's what amped you up
and before you didn't believe it was
possible and so we have talked about a
it is possible and here's why we're
gonna do that that's what I would do and
yeah I would check into Financial Peace
University I'll put you on hold we'll
pay for you to go you know to get into
financial peace will pay for your first
year and get you set up it's a
membership and you go to the class nine
times you go to nine Lessons one one
hour lessons at with a local group and
yes there'll be some in Utah they're all
over the place there's about 14,000
groups operating right now and so
they're fairly easy to get into and it's
all online as well and so will you be on
the road if she goes to a class on
Wednesday night you could watch the same
class online after you park the truck in
the evening and turn around an email or
talk back and forth on the phone about
it and you know you'll be as if you were
there in other words and so getting that
together getting every day every dollar
budget was a great move too by the way
that was a great good direction so the
online works for you know people that
travel a lot and for the military and
that kind of stuff got a lot of military
folks one of them's in the sandbox the
other ones back home and they're taking
the class together because we're doing
it all online you have a one year access
to that with what I'm going to give you
in a one year access to every dollar
plus will upgrade your every dollar to
have the bank connectivity to I'm going
to give you all that this comes with
your Financial Peace University
membership now and join a local group if
you can or at least have her do that at
a minimum but
and be best if you went whether that's
the best thing if you physically can sit
in the in the group together and take
the lessons together that's the best
part best way to do it so hold on I'll
have Kelly pick up and we'll get you to
get you signed up for a year membership
for Financial Peace University